This is not 99% invisible, but I am Roman Mars. This is a special presentation of the newest radio topia podcast, Zigzag. We're in Manou Sumerodi and Genpoion, create a new woman run podcast company called Stable Genius Productions. They're exploring funding through traditional avenues, but also through cryptocurrency. Inside of the reality show that follows their progress, you're going to learn a lot about the digital economy and how decentralized cryptocurrency could change everything. Or not, it's a huge experiment that you don't want to miss.
这不是《99%隐形》，我是罗马·马斯。这是Radiotopia最新播客《之字形》的特别节目。我们身处马努·萨莫罗迪和简·庞恩创办的一家由女性运营的全新播客公司——稳定天才制作公司。他们正在通过传统途径以及加密货币探索融资。在这个记录他们进展的真人秀节目中，你将了解到很多关于数字经济的知识，以及去中心化加密货币将如何改变一切。或者不会改变，这是一个你绝对不想错过的大型实验。
I'm in this episode that we're featuring a whole lot, so I thought that 99 P.I. fans would dig it. It's super fun, but unlike 99% invisible, there is swearing in zigzag, even ice thought that 99 P.I. fans would dig it. It's super fun. But unlike 99% of visible, there is swearing in zigzag, even icewear in zigzag. So I just want to warn you. All right, enjoy. I'm Anouche Summerodi and this is chapter four of Zigzag, a podcast about changing the course of capitalism, journalism, and women in tech. We're exploring these very big ideas through our own personal story. At this point, it's late April, and Jen and I still don't have enough money coming in to pay ourselves.
在本期节目中，我们大量出镜，所以我认为99PI的粉丝会喜欢它。它超级有趣，但与《99%隐形》不同的是，《之字形》里有说脏话，甚至连冰块都在《之字形》里说脏话。所以我只是想提醒你们一下。好了，尽情享受吧。我是阿努什·萨莫罗迪，这是《之字形》的第四章，这是一档关于改变资本主义、新闻业以及科技界女性发展轨迹的播客。我们正通过我们自己的个人故事来探讨这些非常宏大的理念。此时已经是四月下旬，我和简仍然没有足够的收入来给自己发工资。
We're moms. Not having paychecks was giving us stomachaches and eye twitches. Was it time to nail down a plan B, a financial backup? Or is this just how startups work? You just got to knuckle down and wait out the uncertainty. We go looking for those answers in this episode, chapter 4. Specifically, we pitch, sort of, a well-known angel investor, and then go see the co-founder of Radio Topia, Roman Mars, to find out how he built his podcasting empire. This is me and my husband Josh, not to be confused with Josh Benson, our blockchain matchmaker from chapter one. You need to go have a little vacation from your family? Not exactly. It is really early on a Sunday and we're in the car on our way to the airport.
我们是妈妈。没有薪水让我们感到胃痛和眼皮跳动。是时候确定B计划——财务后备方案了吗？还是说初创公司本来就是这样的？你只能咬紧牙关，熬过这段充满不确定性的时期。我们在本期节目（第四章）中寻找这些答案。具体来说，我们向一位知名的天使投资人进行了大致的推介，然后去拜访了Radiotopia的联合创始人罗马·马斯，了解他是如何建立自己的播客帝国的。这是我和我的丈夫乔什，请不要把他和我们在第一章中的区块链红娘乔什·本森混淆。你需要跟你的家人度个小假吗？不完全是。周日一大清早，我们在去机场的路上。
He was going to Puerto Rico. Going with Governor Cuomo. Why are you speaking so slowly? Because it is 5-12 in the morning and it's taking me a little time to formulate my words. Josh covers politics for a local TV news station. We have two kids, but don't worry, my mom was home with them as we scattered ourselves across the globe. I was going to San Francisco.
他要去波多黎各。跟科莫州长一起去。你为什么说话这么慢？因为现在是早上5点12分，我需要花点时间组织语言。乔什为当地的一家电视新闻台报道政治新闻。我们有两个孩子，不过别担心，当我俩各奔东西时，我妈妈在家照顾他们。我要去旧金山。
What are you doing out there again? OK, so I'm going out there. Well, for a multitude of reasons, we're going to pitch an angel investor a first for me. We're going to hang out with Roman Mars for the day, tomorrow in Oakland. What do you think of my hole in Devor so far? Are you worried about any aspects of it? No, I'm worried it's too strong, I term.
你到那边去干什么？好吧，我要去那边。原因有很多，我们要向一位天使投资人进行商业推介，这对我来说还是头一次。明天我们将在奥克兰与罗马·马斯共度一天。你觉得我目前的创业尝试怎么样？你担心它的哪个方面吗？不，我担心它太强大了，我的意思是。
I mean, I'm happy for you, I'm psyched for you. I'm kind of like, just sort of following along. I mean, we like, we've been both very busy, like, giving to my office despite the fact that it's a block away. So instead, we're having the conversation at 514 on the way to the airport. It's our special time, Josh. We should just get up every Sunday morning, around 4 and take a ride to the airport and back. Yes. Josh has been super supportive of me doing this startup thing. I texted our little chat to Jen, who was also headed to the airport to meet me for our flight.
我的意思是，我为你高兴，我为你感到兴奋。我有点像，只是跟着节奏走。我的意思是，我们俩一直都很忙，比如，尽管办公室只有一个街区远，我还是得去上班。所以我们只能在去机场的路上，在5点14分进行这场对话。这是我们的专属时刻，乔什。我们应该每个星期天早上4点左右起床，坐车去机场然后回来。是的。乔什非常支持我做这个初创项目。我把我们的聊天记录发给了简，她也正赶往机场与我汇合。
That was really cute, you guys. Marriage is fascinating. I assume that Josh like new every detail for some reason of what's going on with you right now. So that's pretty funny. And that's badass that you guys both are like, we're both going to do our thing. So fully support. Josh and I are really lucky to have families who live nearby who help out a lot. Jen doesn't have that. Most people don't. But that wasn't stopping both Jen and I from worrying how we were going to make this
你们俩真可爱。婚姻真是奇妙。不知为何，我以为乔什知道你现在发生的一切的每一个细节。所以这挺搞笑的。你们俩都说“我们要去做自己的事”，这真的很酷。非常支持。我很幸运，乔什和我都住在附近的家人能帮上很多忙。简可没有这个条件。大多数人也没有。但这并没有阻止我和简去担心我们该如何制作这个
podcast and run a business. We needed a team. And that takes more than a cryptocurrency that doesn't exist yet. It takes cash. Which is why Genonai decided to go on a reconnaissance mission. A trip to San Francisco. To see if we could find a backup plan, a plan B. Because that's what responsible adults do these days. They don't put their savings on the line. They get rich people to invest in their business. Right? So far, we'd lost our first grant, that was chapter one that we'd been counting on,
播客并经营一家公司。我们需要一个团队。这需要的不仅仅是一种尚不存在的加密货币。它需要现金。这就是为什么简和我决定进行一次侦察任务。去旧金山。看看我们是否能找到一个备用计划，一个B计划。因为这正是现代有责任感的成年人会做的事。他们不会把自己的积蓄押在上面。他们会让有钱人投资他们的生意。对吧？到目前为止，我们失去了第一笔资助，也就是我们在第一章中一直指望的那笔，
that was awful. Then we'd gotten this other small grant that was half in real money, end half in cryptocurrency that still didn't exist yet. It was like Ziggy-D Ziggy-Woo-Woo, but like, maybe it was time to find some stability by having an investor. Well, with that, just create bigger problems. We weren't sure. Jen and I had done our fair share of reporting on tech companies that put their profits ahead of basic humanity to appease shareholders.
那太糟糕了。然后我们得到了另一笔小额资助，一半是真金白银，另一半是尚不存在的加密货币。这就像是“齐吉-D 齐吉-乌乌”（Ziggy-D Ziggy-Woo-Woo），但也许是时候找个投资者来获得一些稳定性了。不过，这会不会带来更大的问题呢？我们并不确定。简和我写过不少关于科技公司的报道，这些公司为了安抚股东，把利润置于基本的人性之上。
But there's also the good side to Silicon Valley. Big ideas can happen because people believe in them and back them was big money. Okay, we just landed. Here's our plan. It's jam-packed. We were meeting with an angel investor named Jess Verrelli that afternoon. And I guess we're going to pitch her, right? Yes, we're pitching her. We're going to tell her our plans. Yeah. See if she gets it. Yeah, hopefully, we're pitching her. We're going to tell her our plans.
但硅谷也有好的一面。伟大的想法之所以能够实现，是因为人们相信它们，并用大笔资金支持它们。好了，我们刚落地。这是我们的计划。行程安排得满满当当。那天下午我们要见一位名叫杰斯·韦雷利的天使投资人。我想我们要向她推介，对吧？是的，我们要向她推介。我们要告诉她我们的计划。是的。看看她能不能理解。是的，希望如此，我们要向她推介。我们要告诉她我们的计划。
Yeah. See if she gets it. Yeah. Hopefully she will. And then, you know, say, what's the next move? A couple hours and a shower later. OK, we are walking down Third Street in the mission to a coffee place to meet Jess Verelli.
是的。看看她能不能理解。是的。希望她会。然后，你知道的，说，下一步是什么？几个小时后，洗了个澡。好了，我们正沿着教会区的第三街散步，去一家咖啡馆见杰斯·韦雷利。
Who's Jess Verelli? She was an early development strategist at Twitter. You've done your homework, Jen, Poion. We got to the coffee shop where we were going to meet Jess a little early. And we just could not stop talking about what we had seen on our walk to the coffee shop. It's definitely the most extreme version of wealth disparity that I've ever seen in America. Yeah, look down and person after homeless person is lying in the streets.
杰斯·韦雷利是谁？她是推特早期的发展战略家。你做过功课了，简·庞恩。我们提前一点到达了我们要见杰斯的咖啡馆。我们简直停不下来，一直在谈论我们在去咖啡馆的路上看到的情景。这绝对是我在美国见过的最极端的财富悬殊现象。是的，往下看，一个又一个无家可归的人躺在街上。
Look up and there are spiffy, extremely wealthy people zipping by on motorized scooters in their ATHLEASURE wear. Jen and I had to abruptly end our conversation about the economics of San Francisco because Jess had arrived. It's here. We all agreed that the cafe was way too noisy. We appreciate that. Can we get you something to go over?
抬头一看，时髦的、极其富有的人穿着运动休闲装，骑着电动滑板车呼啸而过。我和简不得不突然结束关于旧金山经济状况的对话，因为杰斯已经到了。它在这儿。我们一致认为咖啡馆太吵了。我们很感激。我们可以给你打包点什么吗？
I have a picture. There's one coffee for me. I'm going to get some coffee. So we grabbed some ice coffees to go and went down the block to Jess' apartment building. Sir, thank you. She said we could talk in the conference room by the lobby. It's industrial. What's this?
我有一张照片。给我一杯咖啡。我要去买点咖啡。于是我们买了几杯冰咖啡打包，然后走到街区尽头的杰斯公寓楼。先生，谢谢。她说我们可以在大厅旁边的会议室谈。这里很工业风。这是什么？
It's San Francisco, so apartment buildings have conference rooms. Yeah, hi, I'm Jessica Verelli. We were connected through a mutual friend, Crystal Soca, who I've known for a long time. And I am a founding partner of hashtag Angels, which is an investment collective I co-founded with five other women three years ago. And I spent my career working in Silicon Valley at Twitter over eight and a half years
这是旧金山，所以公寓楼里都有会议室。是的，嗨，我是杰西卡·韦雷利。我们是通过共同的朋友克rystal Soca认识的，我认识她很久了。我是#Angels的创始合伙人，这是一个我在三年前与其他五位女性共同创立的投资集体。我的职业生涯都在硅谷度过，在推特工作了八年半，
and started my career actually also working for a venture capital firm. We were frankly initially very resistant or maybe not resistant, but we had reservations or skeptical about going for investment at all because we were a little worried about having to push for these returns. So, online is such a between the last two. That is a smart question for you to ask. I think that is a mark of us, a really thoughtful founder, which is essentially how do I make sure the vision or expectations and hopes I have for my company
我的职业生涯实际上也是从一家风险投资公司开始的。坦率地说，最初我们非常抗拒，或者说不是抗拒，但我们对寻求投资有所保留，或者持怀疑态度，因为我们有点担心必须去追求这些回报。所以，两者的关系就像是……这是一个很聪明的问题。我认为这是一个真正有思想的创始人的标志，本质上是如何确保我对公司的愿景、期望和希望
Align for the expectations of an investor, which is a great question to ask and something that you do want You want to spend a lot of time making sure you get that right? So we're kind of obsessed with it Like we're we talk about it all the time Venture capital is a great way to finance if you want hyper growth. And so hyper growth. Hyper growth. And not to be obtuse about this is the rate of growth and the, like we want to grow, that's going to take anywhere from one to five years I would imagine for us to launch
与投资者的期望相一致，这是一个很好的问题，也是你需要花很多时间去确保做对的事情。所以我们对此有点着迷，就像我们一直在谈论它一样。如果你想要超高速增长，风险投资是一种极好的融资方式。所以超高速增长。超高速增长。为了不故作高深，这就是增长的速度，比如我们想要增长，我估计我们推出三个节目然后将这些节目分拆到不同的多平台，这需要一到五年的时间，这就是增长。但我想问题在于退出策略，你知道的，我们是否会被期望退出？所有关于投资者想拿回什么的问题？预期达到什么水平的增长？我们必须从一开始就知道这一切吗？通常情况下，如果你在筹集风险投资，投资者寻找的是他们相信能够重塑一个行业的企业。这是一场推介会，还是更像是一场辅导课？
three shows and then spin those off into those different multi-platforms, that's growth. But I guess the question is the, maybe the exit strategy, you know, would we be expected to exit all of those questions about like, what do the investors want back? Like, what level of growth is expected and do we have to know all of that at the beginning? Generally, if you're raising venture capital, investors are looking for a business that they believe can transform an industry. Was this a pitch or more like a tutoring session?
我想我的希望是，我想坦诚地说，我们确实希望有投资者能像我们一样深切关怀我们所制作内容的社会影响。这对我来说真的很重要。我的意思是，我绝对希望把公司做大，因为我认为这些想法需要做大，而且它们是大想法。但我也在想，在这个阶段，有没有空间让它……这时简在桌子底下踢了我一脚。
I guess my hope, and I want to be, you know, upfront about it, is that we do have investors who care as deeply as we do about the, you know, the societal impact of the stuff that we make. That's really important to me. I mean, I definitely want to be big because I think these ideas need to be big and they're big ideas. But I also think, like, is there room for that to be, at this point, Jen kicked me under
有良知。她后来告诉我那是无意的。但在当时，我还以为你想让我闭嘴。我想是的，我认为这全在于找到与投资者的合适契合点，鉴于这一点对你有多重要，鉴于这可能会凌驾于增长之上。
the table. conscientious. By accident, she told me later. But at the time, I thought you wanted me to shut up. I think so, I think it's all about finding that right fit with an investor and given how important that is to you and given that might trump growth.
我认为，像你现在这样，明确说出你对此的目标以及成功对你意味着什么，将有助于你找到价值观高度一致的投资者。你知道吗，这听起来对你来说很遥远吗？它将有助于你找到价值观高度一致的投资者。你知道吗，这听起来对你来说很遥远吗？等一下，我们向某人推介以资助我们的工作，而这项工作基本上会批评那些他们也资助过的科技平台，这不是很奇怪吗？
I think being as exactly as you are being rather explicit about what your goals are for this and what success looks like to you is gonna help you find an investor that were that aligned. Do you know, does this sound like far-fetch like to you is going to help you find an investor that were that aligned. Do you know any, does it sound like far-fetched to you? Wait, was this weird that we were kind of pitching someone to fund our work, which would basically criticize the tech platforms that they had also funded?
我认为这些人是存在的。我想花更多时间和你探讨你想要建立的事业的雄心，以及那种商业模式和规模可能会是什么样子的。是的。这个阶段应该完全围绕打造产品和从客户那里获取反馈。如果你现在就需要钱，那么你必须稍微思考一下，比如，什么是正确的资金来源，
I think these people exist. I think I want to spend a little bit more time with you on the ambition for what you want to build and what that business and scale might look like. Yeah. This phase should be all about building the product and getting feedback from customers. If you need money right now, then you have to think a little bit about like, okay, what is the right source to,
无论是收入、赠款还是种子轮融资。但是，如果你在重新进入募资模式之前还有一点时间的话，我不认为我们有。我认为我们需要种子轮融资。但是，如果你在重新进入募资模式之前还有一点时间的话，我不认为我们有。我认为我们需要种子轮融资。我的意思是，像赠款这样的东西，我们正在申请，但它们需要时间才能落实。就像这个过程往往非常官僚主义。我们可能会有赞助，我的意思是，赞助。但这需要时间，你知道，你需要节目播出来。直到赞助资金像这样。我们绝对得
whether it's revenue or grants or seed funding. But if you have a little bit of time before you're back in a fundraising mode, I don't think we do. I think we need seed funding. But if you have a little bit of time before you're back in a fundraising mode, I don't think we do. I think we need seed funding. I mean, grants like we can, we're in the process of applying, but they take time to get to happen. Just like the process is very often very bureaucratic. And we might have sponsorship, I mean, well, sponsorship. But that takes time to, you know, you need the shows to come out. Until the sponsorship money like this. We're definitely gonna have to
陷入债务，除非我们能找到一些种子投资人。我想基本上就是这样。不，这是对的。是的，肯定的。她还没看手表呢，但你是不是觉得我们在浪费她的时间？老实说，你们俩在这里承担了大部分风险。所以关键在于找到与那些相信你们、相信你们正在构建的事业的人的正确契合点。所以朋友和家人可能会提供资助。你到目前为止分享的内容确实表明，影响力投资者可能更适合，但我不想草率下结论，需要进行推介并真正深入探讨。听起来你拥有做这件事的不可思议的背景。
go into debt unless we get some seat funders. I think that's basically what. No, that's correct. Yeah, for sure. She hadn't looked at her watch yet, but did you just think we were wasting her time? Truthfully, you all are taking most of the risk here. And so it's about finding the right alignment with folks that believe in you and believe in what you're building. So friends and family around may be possible. What you've shared so far does seem like something where the impact investors might be the better fit, but I don't want to jump to that conclusion to a page and it's like really like talk through that. It sounds like you have an incredible background to do this.
你在之前的职位上通过这样做取得了成功。所以我想问你的是，我能看看那个吗？我能听听那个吗？我能听听其中的一些反馈吗？试着证实这是真的。然后，一个公开的问题是，这笔生意能有多大？这是不是下一个像海啸一样的全球媒体公司？这是不是某种能变得非常庞大的事物的种子？
You've been successful doing this in your prior roles. And so I would ask you to like, can I take a look at that? Can I listen to that? Can I hear some of that feedback? Try to validate that that's true. And then the open question though is like, how big of a business is this? Is this the next like massive like global media company? Is this the seed of something that can be really big?
这真的是他们想要打造的吗？他们相信有一条实现这一目标的道路吗？好吧，所以我们要这么做。我们能以多快的速度在本周回来再做一次？真的吗？太好了。真的吗？好吧，所以我想我们应该去谈谈，然后决定我们是否想这么做。哦，我想我们绝对想这么做，对吧？
And is that what they want to build? Do they believe there's a path to doing that? Okay, so we were gonna do that. Could we, how quickly could we come back and do that this week? Yes. Yeah. Cool. Really? Yeah. Okay, so I think what we should do is go talk and decide whether we want to do that. Oh, I think we definitely want to do that, don't we?
绝对想这么做。好吧，我只是想确保我们绝对想这么做。我们是合作伙伴，所以我想确保你想做，因为我想做。是的，绝对的。非常感谢。不客气。谢谢。不用谢。
Definitely want to do that. Okay, I just wanted to make sure that we definitely want to do that. We're partners, so I want to make sure that you want to do it, because I want to do it. Yeah, absolutely. Thank you so much. You're very welcome. Thank you. You're super welcome.
很高兴认识你们俩。我和简走出杰斯的办公室，带着震惊和眩晕，跌跌撞撞地走进了旧金山清脆春夜渐暗的微光中。多么奇怪的经历！我们在风险投资家面前表现得像是一个团结的整体，但与此同时，我们的脑子里却在通过心灵感应进行交流。别这么做，做这个？你想这么做？我不知道，别这么做。
Nice to meet you both. Jen and I walked out of our meeting with Jess and kind of stumbled, stunned into the waning light of a crisp spring evening in San Francisco. What a weird experience! We had presented a united front to avenge your capitalists, but meanwhile our brains had been talking to each other like ESP. Don't do this, do this? Do you want to do this? I don't know, don't do this.
好吧，刚好两个小时。她说她会跟我们见两个小时。她真的跟我们见了整整两个小时。她说她会跟我们见两个小时。她跟我们见了整整两个小时。顺便说一句，自那次会议以来，杰斯被任命为谷歌支持的风险投资基金GV的最新合伙人。所以至少她知道自己在做什么。简和我需要总结一下并吃晚饭。
Alright, that was exactly two hours. She said she'd meet with us for two hours. She met with us for exactly two hours. She said she'd be with us for two hours. She met with us for exactly two hours. Since that meeting, by the way, Jess has been named the newest partner at the Google-backed venture capital firm, GV. So at least she knew what she was doing. Jen and I needed to debrief and eat dinner.
哦，菊苣沙拉加更多的培根吃起来不好吃。是的，一个主菜还是任何开胃菜？我想只要主菜就行。 yeah. 我觉得那太糟糕了。就像一场灾难。你真的这么觉得？你为什么会有这种感觉？
Oh, the frisay salad and more bacon doesn't taste good. Yes, one main course or any appetizers? I think just the main course. Yeah. I feel like that was bad. Like a disaster. You do? Why do you feel that way?
这太有趣了。因为这不是，我想在我们的直觉中，她知道，我们也知道这并不合适。就像，我绝对想推介这个，我当时想，哦，我很惊讶。我感到相当不自在。当然，我也是。我们一直留在媒体行业。
That's so interesting. It's because it's not, I think in our guts, she knew and we knew that it's not the right fit. Like, I definitely wanna pitch this and I was like, oh, I'm surprised. I felt pretty out of my comfort zone. Sure, me too. We've stayed in the media business.
就像，我们两个都喜欢它。我们喜欢这里的人，我们喜欢强调创意而不是估值。我只是不想考虑钱的事。对我来说，最大的奢侈就是不用一直想着钱。我现在不能假装自己是商业人士，但我们必须这样做。我明白，但我的目标然后
Like, we both like it. We like the people who are in it and we like the emphasis on ideas as opposed to valuation. And I just don't want to be thinking about money. Like to me, the greatest luxury is not to be thinking about money all the time. I can't wear a business people now, we have to. I understand that, but my goal then
是达到不用考虑钱的境界。我的目标不是去弄什么资本……资本结构表？对，还有所有那些。真的不是。就像，我不认为。就像，我非常关心的是和你一起做东西，并感受到那种创作的……
is to get to where I don't have to think about money. My goal is not to like have caps and... Cap tables? Yeah, and all of that. It's really not. Like, I don't think. Like, I really care very much about like, making stuff with you and feeling that creative...
惊奇感，以及人们被我们制作的东西所打动的感觉，这对我来说非常重要。哦，对我也很重要。我只是不知道我们要怎么做。这就让我想到，好吧，这不对劲。我们甚至还想回去真正尝试向她推介吗？我的意思是，听起来好像不想。
Wonder and like, people feeling moved by the things that we make and like, that matters a lot to me. Oh, matters to me too. I just don't know how we're gonna do it. That leads me to, okay, this wasn't right. Like, do we even wanna go back and actually try and pit her? I mean, it sounds like no.
短期内，她有点像是说，靠赠款、家人和朋友。对。我认为更重要的事情是我们接下来要做什么。比如，我们拼命工作直到这个节目上线，然后我们回到那种模式，看看赞助从哪里来，然后我们一起以慢得多的速度发展它。这里面没有什么可耻的吗？
In the short term, she kinda said like, grants and family and friends. Right. I think the bigger thing is what we're gonna do. Like, we work our asses off until we launch this show, and then we go back to like a model where we just see where the sponsorship comes and we grow it way slower together. And there's no like, is there shame in that?
我觉得我们觉得这很可耻。但我只是，让我害怕的是丹一直告诉我们那是不可能的。丹是一位商业顾问，他一直在帮我们预测未来的预算和收入。我是说，说真的，我们明天必须和罗马重新把整个谈话进行一遍。是的。
I feel like we feel like there's shame in that. But I just, what scares me is Dan keeps telling us that that's not possible. Dan was a business consultant who was helping us project future budgets and revenue. I mean, seriously, we need to have this entire conversation over again with Roman tomorrow. Yeah.
这将会是，这将会是完全不同的。我不认为这有什么可耻的。这本质上就是回到真正的白手起家模式。然后看看我们从那里走向何方。所以我对此很好。我对此很好。那就是，是的，完全没问题。
It's gonna be, it's gonna be completely different. I don't think there's any shame in that. That's essentially going back to like the real bootstrapping model. And then seeing where we go from there. So I'm fine with that. I'm fine with that. Which is, yeah, some totally fine with it.
好吧。真奇怪，我觉得，你知道，这里有这么多的数额，在很多方面是如此的功利，没有太多的灵魂。你这么说让我太高兴了。对。真的很高兴。是的，真的吗？
All right. It's weird how you, I feel like, you know, there's so many amounts here, which is so utilitarian in many ways, there's not a ton of soul. It makes me so happy, you said that. Right. It really does. Yeah, really?
是的，老兄，你知道我很讲究灵魂。我的意思是，不是那种，是的，为什么我们不是那种呼吸法式的？是的。哈哈。我觉得另一件很奇怪的事情是，我们如此坚信，而且我们是女性，我们能做到这一点。
Yeah, dude, you know I'm very much about soul. I mean, not like in the, yeah, yeah, why do we mean not like, breathe a frank like that? Yes. Yeah. I think the other thing that's so strange I mean that like in the... Hey, why don't we not like breathe a frankly? Yes. Hahaha. I think the other thing that's so strange is that we believe so wholeheartedly and like, we are women, we could do this.
为什么不抓住这个机会呢？这太疯狂了。不抓住才怪。但这不适合我们。这很难。这就是为什么我觉得这是一场灾难，因为我想，这感觉像是一场灾难吗？让我明确一点。你知道我意识到什么吗？就像我的一部分心想，
Why don't we take that opportunity? This is crazy. Not to. But it's not right for us. And that's hard. That's why it feels like a disaster to me because I'm like, does it feel like a disaster? Let me be clear. You know what I'm realizing? It's like part of me was like,
是的，我们会向你推介，因为我觉得我太担心在金钱上让你失望了。你承担了。就像，你承担了。我也担心同样的事，老兄。我承担了很大的风险，但你，你已经投入了很多。所以我担心会有大风险，但你已经投入了很多。所以我担心同样的事。我的意思是，并不是说我们没有一些资金进来。对。
yes, we'll pitch you because I think I'm so worried about letting you down, money wise. You're taking it. Like, you're taking it. I'm worried about the same thing, dude. I'm taking a big risk, but you're, you've invested a lot already into it. So I'm worried about big risk, but you've invested a lot already into it. So I'm worried about the same thing. I mean, it's not like we don't have some money coming in. Right.
对。别忘了代币。别忘了代币。哦，看起来很好吃。太棒了。我想吃一块你的薯条。非常感谢。好的，请吧。太棒了。
Right. Don't forget the tokens. Don't forget the tokens. Oh, that looks yummy. Great. And I want to eat one of your french fries. Thank you so much. Yes, please. That's beautiful.
非常感谢。好的，请吧。太棒了。哇。等等。我们真的很需要资金支持来让我们的使命导向型新闻报道成为可能，我们也真正需要彼此的坦诚。现在，我们拥有了后者。
So much. Yes, please. That's beautiful. Wow. Hold on. We really wanted financial support to make our mission-based journalism possible, and we really wanted honesty from each other. Right now, we have the latter.
你正在收听的是《99%隐形》特别呈献的《之字形》。接下来，简和马努什来到奥克兰，我将在那里传授一些冷静的智慧。我们正在推出《之字形》第四章。想要跟随“稳定天才”们在女性媒体和科技领域开辟新道路的步伐，请访问zigzagpod.com进行订阅。你可能听过我们在前三集结束时说过我们是Radiotopia的自豪成员。
You're listening to a special presentation of Zigzag on 99% of visible. Coming up Jen and Manouche come to Oakland where I'd dispense some chill wisdom. We are featuring episode 4 of Zigzag. To follow along with the staple geniuses is they forward a new path for women in media and tech. Go to zigzagpaw.com to subscribe. You've probably heard us say that we are proud members of Radio Topia at the end of the first three episodes.
有些人可能会说，我们要感谢Rapper POS让我们得以进入那个精彩的播客集体。去年他出了一首名为《Wearing a Bear》的歌，他在歌里向我和Radiotopia的夏日派对以及罗马·马斯致敬。杯架边缘，低沉温热的苏打水，但乘客的却是冰凉刺骨，压下压力，然后当快死时，我会得到一个标签，吐得更好。现在，简和我成了Radiotopia的最新成员，这意味着我们拥有我们所有的作品。我以前和罗马交往过，但他和简从未见过面。当他建议我们去找他共度一天时，我们俩都超级兴奋。我听说过Glass，
Some might say that we have rapper POS to thank for our entree into that awesome podcasting collective. Last year he put out a song called Wearing a Bear and he gave shoutouts to me and radio topia's summer party in Roman Mars is wippy, yeah, whip, whip, and scrub, bend in the corners of the cup holder, low warm flat soda, but the passenger's ice cold, pushing down the pressure, then when a die, I'll get a hashtag, a spit better. Now Jen and I were the newest members of Radiotopia, and that meant we owned all our work. I had hung out with Roman before, but he and Jen had never met. And when he suggested that we come out to spend the day with him, we were both super psyched. I heard glass,
Jad，Album Rod，罗马·马斯。这些都是叙事音频讲故事领域的伟大名字。所以这有点像是去“吻戒指”，只不过他们全都是公共广播界的书呆子酷。所以……不对劲。输入代码拨打电话。但在某种程度上，那天早上，简和我绝对一点都不酷。他妈的。光是进大楼对我们来说就是一场挣扎。嗨，我正试图联系罗马·马斯。你知道他在哪一层吗？
jad, album rod, Roman Mars. These are the great names and narrative audio storytelling. So it was kind of like going to kiss the ring, except all of them are public radio, nerdy cool. so... Not really. Enter code to place call. But in a way, that morning, Jen and I were most definitely not cool. Motherfucker. Just getting into the building seemed to be a struggle for us. Hi there, I'm trying to get in touch with Roman Mars. Do you know which floor he's on?
非常抱歉，谢谢。跟杰斯的谈话肯定比我们想象的更让我们心神不宁。开始？我们有密码。我知道，但是哦。我们有密码。我们有密码。好吧，现在试试。我们走。太好了！
I'm so sorry, thanks. That conversation with Jess must have rattled us more than we knew. Start? We have the code. I know, but oh. We have the code. We have the code. Okay, let's try now. Here we go. Yes!
我知道吗？我们走。太好了！啊，卡内尔。多少？就是这个。哇，真好。嗨。嗨。你好吗？很好。我们是马努什和简，我们要去找罗马。这是简。
Can I know? Here we go. Yes! Ah cannell. How many? This is it. Wow it's nice. Hi. Hi. How are you? Good. We're Maneucia and Jen and we're going to see Roman. This is Jen.
嗨。很高兴认识你。我也很高兴认识你。我们直接进去了，我们要去找罗马。太棒了。这是简。嗨。很高兴认识你。我也很高兴认识你。我们直接切入正题。那是罗马。老兄，我们经历了疯狂的24小时。你们是什么时候到的？昨天。
Hi. It's so nice to meet you. Nice to meet you too. We got right and we're gonna be Roman. Awesome. This is Jen. Hi. It's so nice to meet you. Nice to meet you too. We got right into it. It was Roman. Dude, we've had like an insane 24 hours. What did you arrive? Yesterday.
然后我们昨晚突然有了顿悟。哦，天哪。但我们需要你的帮助，因为……哦，我们已经在录音了。哦，对。我们满了。我们一直是公共广播制作人，制作节目，哦，我们已经在录音了。哦，对。有什么问题吗？他曾是一名公共广播制作人，制作节目，几乎挣不到什么钱，当播客开始腾飞时
And then we had like an epiphany last night. Oh, goodness. But we need your help because... Oh, we're already recording. Oh yeah. We're full. We've been a public radio producer, making shows, Oh, we're already recording. Oh yeah. Where's the fall? He's been a public radio producer, making shows, barely making any money, when podcasting started taking off
大约五六年前。他去了PRX，他们决定专注于此。前身为播客们拥有自己作品的集体。他们不再担心制作广播节目，而是把播客当作一项生意来做，或者至少能过上体面的生活，同时仍然制作出色的公共广播风格的内容。罗马和Radiotopia进行了Kickstarter历史上最成功的众筹活动之一。我是罗马·马斯。我是《99%隐形》的主持人，也是PRX旗下Radiotopia的联合创始人。
about five or six years ago. He went to PRX and they decided to just concentrate on that. Former collective were the podcasters owned their work. They'd stop worrying about making radio shows and make a business out of podcasting, or at least a decent living, still doing great public radio style content. Roman and radio Topia had done one of the most successful Kickstarter campaigns in the history of Kickstarter. I am Roman Mars. I am the host of 99% of visible, and I am the co-founder of Radio Topia from PRX.
我们正坐在你的办公室里。是的，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。罗马当年确实冒了很大的财务风险。我的意思是，对我来说，这就像任何其他生意一样。所以你赚了足够的钱来支付一份或两份薪水，然后你看着办，你赚了足够的钱来增加另一个人，再增加另一个人，
And we're sitting in your office. Yes, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Roman had definitely taken some big financial risks in his time. I mean, to me, it's just like it's a business like any other. So you make enough money to pay a salary or two, and then you see, and you make enough money to add another person, add another person,
然后你赚了足够的钱，剩下的钱可以享受拥有一个东西带来的好处。这花了我很长时间，我做99PI已经快八年了，刚开始运营的时候，我是不给自己发工资的。我的意思是，有没有那么几个万念俱灰的时刻，比如，操，如果这不管用怎么办？我只是觉得你随时都能找到工作。那么在这种情况下，失败意味着什么？失败意味着你做了其他人都在做的事。这其实不算失败，对吧？
then you make enough money to have money left over to reap the benefits of owning a thing. And it took me, and I've been doing 99PI for almost eight years, and the way it operated in the beginning was that I didn't pay myself. I mean, were there moments where you were like, fuck, what if this doesn't work? I just feel like you can always get a job. So what does failure mean in this case? Failure means you do the thing that everyone else does. That's not really failure, right?
对，没错。所以，我不知道，我没有，我现在比以前更害怕了。是的，因为我有10名员工。然后，然后Radiotopia本身，比如运营Radiotopia的很多收入是我节目的分成，因为我的节目带来了大量的广告收入。所以现在我觉得，好吧，我最好继续努力拼搏。这感觉不一样。我们一直在努力决定是完全资助这个节目，还是做决定，我想
Right, so that's true. So like, I don't know, I didn't, I feel more scared of it now than I did then. Yeah, because I have 10 employees. And then, and then radio topia itself, like a lot of the revenue that operates radio topia is the percentage of my show because my show brings in a lot of ad revenue. And so like, now I feel like, well, now I better keep hustling. It's like different. We've been struggling to decide how to fully fund the show or to have to decide, I suppose
我们一直在讨论我们是应该寻求投资、获得赞助，还是仅仅制作节目然后通过这种方式获得赞助。嗯，很大一部分，我的意思是，你应该把所有这些都做。在某种程度上，就Radiotopia的筹款而言，因为我们有一种模式，支持那些无法完全依靠广告收入维持自身的节目，我们真的很需要捐款来支持整个节目阵容，
we've been talking about whether we should seek out investment or get grants or just make the thing and then get the sponsorship that way. Well, a huge part, I mean, you should do all of it. In a way, in terms of radio, topia fundraising, because we have a model which supports shows that can't support themselves completely as advertising based, we really need donations to support the slate,
就像整个节目阵容一样。对我们来说，必须这样做就像是我们创作艺术的方式，而不是去追逐商业利益。对。你刚才说的话，“艺术而非商业”，正好总结了你和我一直在进行的灵魂搜索，简。所以我们不断被问到的问题是，
like the whole slate of shows. And we have to do that to me is like, that's how we make art, rather than chase commerce. Right. What you just said, art rather than commerce kind of sums up the soul searching that you and I have been doing, Jen. So the question that we keep getting is,
你们想要什么？这取决于你们想要什么。你们想要什么？好吧，你们想要什么？这取决于你们想要什么。你们想要什么？你们想要什么？我觉得我们离弄清楚自己想要什么越来越近了。嗯，我想这是因为马努什开始以这些方式取得成功，她开始被邀请去演讲。她在做TED演讲，所以我们自然能看到一个比单纯一个节目更大的可行模式。
what do you want? It depends what you want. What do you want? Well, what do you want? It depends what you want. What do you want? What do you want? And it's like, I think we're getting closer to knowing what we want. Well, I think it's because Venush was starting to succeed in these ways where she was being asked to speak. She was doing the TED Talk, so we could naturally see a model that would work that was bigger
我们正准备记录这段经历，包括制作节目、打造这个业务，以及我们刚刚讨论的所有不同选择，对吧？在录音带上承认所有这些让人感觉非常脆弱。是的，我能理解。庆幸的是我当时没有记录下来。是的，特别是作为两个女性公开这么做。但你也会，是的，我懂，我也明白这是一个风险。
than just a show. We are about to document this experience, both of making the show, making this business, all the different choices that we're just talking about, right? And it feels very vulnerable to admit all of this on tape. Yeah, I can see that. I'm glad I wasn't documenting that. Yeah, especially publicly as too women to do it. But you also, yeah, I get that and I get that that's a risk.
但你也会从中获得很多力量。再说一次，这就像是风险与回报的平衡，你承担了更大的风险，也能获得丰厚的回报。是的，回报可能会很大，对吧？可能会很大。而且，这也就像是，我坚信你的人生目标就是过一种非凡的生活，比如过一种奇特的生活。
But you also, you're gonna get a lot of strength from that too. Again, it's like this balance of risk and reward and you have greater risk and lots of reward. Yeah, the reward could be big, right? It could be big. And also, it's just like, I fully believe that your goal in life is to live an extraordinary life, like live a weird life.
是的。我认为这是真的，而且我认为外面有很多女性需要听到其他女性这样做。你知道的，我们向很多人征求过很多建议，每当涉及商业时，所有的建议似乎都是：嗯，生意是这样运作的，你做不到这一点。就像，有很多人对我们说，这行不通。嗯，这取决于你有什么样或想要什么样的业务。我完全，我认为。
Yeah. I think that's true, and I think there are a lot of women out there that need to hear other women doing this. You know, we've asked for a lot of advice from a lot of people, and every bit of advice when it comes to business seems to be like, well, the way a business works, like, you're not going to be able to do this. Like, we've had a lot of people kind of say, like, it's not going to work. Well, it depends on what type of business you have or want. I totally, I think.
简，你想要什么？你想要什么？你想要什么？但就像，你知道的，媒体是一个糟糕的初创公司，却是一门好生意。因为它无法按照他们希望的方式带来资金回报。如果你非要这样做，你就必须成长并制作你不关心的事情。但如果你只是想制作一个节目并给自己发工资，你可以做到。那并不是一座难以逾越的高山。你可以做到。然后从那里开始，你会开始觉得，我认为在处理这种事情时要顺从直觉。开始去觉得，我认为在处理这种事情时要顺从直觉
What do you want, Jen? What do you want? What do you want? But like, you know, like, media is a bad startup in a good business. Because it doesn't return money the way they want it to. And if you do, you have to grow and make things that you don't care about. But if you just want to make a show and pay yourselves, you can do that. That is not that steep hill to climb. You could do that. And then from there, you begin to go, I think that you follow your gut when it comes to that stuff. to go, I think that you follow your gut
。就我个人而言，我认为没有不附带条件的金钱。我唯一喜欢的、附带条件的金钱来自观众。好吧，所以我要表现得非常商业化，但我把它转回去了还是怎么的。
when it comes to that stuff. And personally, I think that there's no money without strings attached. The only money I've ever, that has strings attached that I like is money from the audience. Okay, so I'm gonna be very like, business-y, but turn it all or something.
你存了多少钱。我的意思是，你存了一年的钱吗？你能在不赚钱的情况下生活吗？我绝对不能。我大概只剩两个月的积蓄了。好吧。所以，你需求中的这种不对称，会导致你在做选择时产生紧张感吗？我可以说开始时确实如此，当时我想，好吧，如果我要投资这家公司，我想拥有它更多股份。简说，不。
How much you got saved. I mean, do you have a year saved? Can you live without making any money? I definitely cannot. I have like two months maybe left. Okay. So, is that asymmetry in your needs? Does that cause attention in your choices? I would say it did at the beginning where I was like, well, if I'm gonna invest in the company, I wanna own more of it. And Jen said, no.
不。不。我担心……嗯，她的风险更高。我的意思是，你们在投入不同的东西。完全正确。是的。对。
No. No. I worry that like. Well, her risk is higher. I mean, there's a way you're putting in different things. Exactly. Yeah. Right.
我的意思是，如果公司永远无法还我钱，那就……是的。那将是另一回事。那是为了……那将是另一回事。那是为了……我就是这么想的。我的意思是，说实话，金钱就是自由。这就是它的用处。
I mean, if the company can never pay me back, that's. Yeah. That'll be its own thing. It's money for. That'll be its own thing. That's money for. That's what I kind of think. I mean, really, money is freedom. That's what it's for.
我的意思是，拥有股权难的地方在于，在它变得可持续之前，资金耗尽前的时间必须相当长。如果这段时间很短，那么它实际上会搞砸可持续性。我想我们在试图弄清楚，如果我们不搞风险投资，通过所有这些不同的资金来源我们能筹集到的最低限度是多少，并且仍然能维持自己，直到资金耗尽前的时间足够长，让它真正变得可持续。我的意思是，就是这样。你必须做好准备，在它行不通时认清现实。但只是想想，比如什么？
I mean, the hard part of ownership is that the runway has to be kind of long before you get to the point where it's sustainable. And if the runway is short, then it actually, it fucks with the sustainability. I think we're trying to figure out what's the minimum we can pull in through all these various funding sources if we're not going to do the VC thing and still sustain ourselves until that runway gets long enough for it to become really sustainable. I mean, that's the thing. You have to be prepared to recognize when it's not working. But just think like, like what?
如果你没有太多的其他压力，要抓紧一个你或许不该抓紧的东西其实挺容易的。什么会让你把这一切给结束掉？这是一个非常好的问题。是的，但你知道，这太难回答了。因为如果你当初对《自我注意》问我这个问题，我不会……我的意思是，事情发生了，你根本不知道。是的。
It's kind of easy, if you don't have a lot of other pressures, to hold on to something that you maybe shouldn't be holding on to. What would make you sunset this whole thing? That's a really good question. Yeah, but you know, it's that is so hard to answer. Because if you had asked me that about note to self, I wouldn't have, I mean, should happens and you have no idea. Yeah.
什么会让我把这一切给结束掉？是一个更好的机会吗？就像，不会，因为这是最好的机会。但让我问你这个。你难道就永远只做99PI吗？嗯，我也在想这个。我给自己设定了一个截止日期，一种时间表，我需要把它做到尽可能成功。我现在43岁了。我不知道它会不会在我50岁时结束。我想我可能会更快地走你的路线。
What would make me sunset this whole thing? Is it a better opportunity? It's like, no, because this is the best opportunity. But let me ask you this. Do you just make 99PI forever? Well, I wonder that too. I've given myself a dead, a kind of a timeline of, I need to make it as successful as possible. I'm 43 now. I don't know if the end of it's going to happen when I'm 50. I think I would probably go your route faster.
就像现在，人们在“99%隐形”这个群体内部做项目，这对世界来说将是新鲜事物。我真的不能谈论它们，但我们可以说这么多。我可以想象，我的生活不再是主持节目，而是经营一家店。另外，我也感到前所未有的疲惫。我只想结束采访，但你们确实在冒险。哦，不，但这是一种很好的冒险。
Like right now, we're people are doing projects inside of the group of nine percent of us will, which will be new things for the world. And I can't really talk about them, but we can say this much. I could imagine that my life is not hosting a show, but running a shop. Also, I feel myself more tired than I ever have. And I just can the interview, but like, you guys are taking a chance. Oh no, but it's a good chance.
就像，这就是重点。这更像是你们的冒险。这就是Radiotopia管用的原因。就像，我不拥有它。你知道，我们不拥有它。这是你们去承担的冒险。我们只是得以成为其中一部分。我们喜欢成为我们引以为傲的事物的一部分。我们与罗马的会面感觉像是一场充满动力的励志谈话，但我们不需要
Like it's like, that's the thing. It's like, it's more your chance. That's why radio topia works. It's like, I don't own it. You know, we don't own it. It's your chance to take. We just get to be a part of it. And we like to be a part of things that we're proud of. Our session with Roman kind of felt like a motivational pep talk, but we didn't have to
像在托尼·罗宾斯的活动上那样站在椅子上大喊大叫。这场励志谈话要冷静态得多。谢谢。谢谢。不，这是我的荣幸。很高兴听到这些。这场对话正是我们所需要的。简和我下定了决心。
stand on chairs and yell like at a Tony Robbins event. This pep talk was way more children than that. Thank you. Thank you. No, it's my pleasure. I'm so happy to hear. This conversation was just what we needed. Jan and I were resolved.
现在投资资金不适合我们。又是一个之字形弯道，然后我们安顿下来。我们知道我们需要专注于制作播客，这个播客。坚守使命。然后如果我们能走到那一步，我们再重新评估。于是我们回到了纽约，甚至在日历上的一个夏日四周画了一个大红圈，并把它命名为“财务清算日”。但知道我们不仅有一个，而且有两个集体的支持，感觉真好——罗马和Radiotopia，他们正在分发这个节目、销售赞助以及……使用区块链的实验。
Investment money for now was not for us. Another zig, and then we sacked. We knew that we needed to focus on making the podcast, this podcast. Stick to the mission. And then if we made it that far, we'd reassess. So we went back to New York and we even put a big red circle around one summer day on the calendar and we labeled it Financial Reckoning Day. But it felt good to know we had the support of not just one, but two collectives, Roman and radiotopia who are distributing this show and selling sponsorship and civil. The experiment using the blockchain
眼下的投资不属于我们。又一个曲折之后，我们被解雇了。我们知道我们需要专注于制作播客，这个播客。坚守使命。如果能坚持到那个地步，我们再重新评估。于是我们回到了纽约，甚至在日历上的一个夏日画了一个大红圈，称之为“财务清算日”。但知道我们不仅得到了一个，而是两个集体的支持，感觉很好，罗马和Radiotopia正在分发这个节目并出售赞助和Civil。使用区块链的实验
to create a new ecosystem for independent journalists. Sure, the whole thing was dicey, but they had given us just enough money to pay the bills, and maybe the token thing would actually work. Anyway, the civil people felt like are people. like our people. your podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为独立记者创造一个全新的生态系统。当然，整个事情充满风险，但他们给我们的资金刚好够付清账单，说不定代币这套方案真的能行。无论如何，这些文明人感觉就像是我们自己人。像我们的人。你的播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。